parler de ce métier connaît que tout le
monde subit alors qu'on arrive
exactement le genre de salle de koné
s'est délité moi j'essaie de mon travail
d'éviter la mécanique peut sortir tous
les organes de ventilation de
climatisation peut faire ça
naturellement voilà de faire à marseille
on peut faire à lille où il opère en
chine
tout juste s'en donner les moyens il
faut juste y croire il faut beaucoup
être inventifs sachant qu'aujourd'hui il
m'a dit fais le pari politique mais en
fait je pense que notre métier est
éminemment politique que l'architecte et
surtout pas un artiste il a une
dimension créative artistique dans son
travail mais ça n'est pas un artiste
c'est le contraire de frank ghery la
guérite la grand sculpteur moi c'est pas
un architecte
donc j'ai commencé ma carrière en
vendant les risques absolument fou grâce
à un élu la première image c'est donc
l'audace d'un jean bousquet maire de
nîmes qui je veux courir les arènes de
nîmes devant l'appel divers la découvre
et on l'a perdue et énoncer un concours
moi je suis jeune architecte associé
avec un avance présente le concours est
abandonnée on continue je n'ai rien à
perdre
et puis ont mis au point cette lentille
diplomatique de 90 mètres de long 60 m
de large la plus grande au monde
là les hawks et xla pas de cas en partie
supérieure
on amène la maquette devant jean
bousquet t il dit c'est formidable c'est
un geste e romain audi marque aucune
référence
on avait juste un très bon ingénieur il
est passé sa thèse en matière de bio
pneumatiques et un jour on arrive dans
l'hymne n'était pas très aventures des
voyages en volvo sont associés tonghai
que l'étalement est un architecte connu
maintenant on arrive dans la ville de
nîmes après avoir passé la nuit au
volant donc un peu crevé je vois des
énormes affiches le projet n'est pas
fait encore l'audace ça marche
et puis pratiquement ce dessin la soie
ou titre vous dire que c'était très
compliqué pour les monuments historiques
pour la structure technique pour le
contrôle incendie etc
c'était sa grand mère mais ça a été très
vite le projet aux 87 et la lisant des
190 unités pendant 20 ans
voilà noda ça marche ça veut dire que
tous les projets ambitieux je rejoins le
script éditeur nécessite une volonté
politique deuxième projet audacieux
un peu plus tard
nous c'est pareil depuis déjà dix
projets jeudi un ensemble très peu
d'argent un gymnase de type c'est
d'ailleurs à 1,40 par 20 le problème
c'est que le terrain qui nous est donnée
à grenoble faisait 40 par 20 donc il
faut quand même être des vestiaires une
entrée etc
donc soit on était les vestiaires en
haut on dit tu sais tu mènes kir et
descendre à la salle de sport facile à
comprendre mais le sport un bar un peu
idiot de faire monter les étudiants et
les élèves et les faits redescend donc
on met les vestiaires au niveau du sol
pas en sous sol ça n'est pas le loyer
les glo et on met la salle au dessus
voilà bah moi aussi le problème c'est
que quand on fait une dalle et non pas
du dallage de salsa coûte deux fois plus
cher est que le budget on n'a jamais pu
avoir le budget correspondant
l'opération est donc on est au point un
système pas tellement révolutionnaire
juste juste un peu simple à comprendre
ce qu'il a dit mais la pression est là
il ya eu des efforts latéraux à
reprendre françois nadale et puis on n'a
pas d'argent pour la façade comme on dit
c'est grâce à de couverture on va
chercher en carbonate bleus qui protège
un peu dire une seule est le moins cher
d'ailleurs mais pas de faux plafonds et
on met les essais de soucoupe qu'on a
fait faire par un matelassiers le lion
les matelas qui est venue sur place pour
les matelas les capitons on a mis la
lumière
et puis et puis on a mis la ventilation
naturelle traversant ce n'est pas brad
hurle écrit tout ça est sorti à 600 700
euros le mètre carré ça vous parle pas
beaucoup c'est à dire à peu près deux
fois moins cher qu'un projet normal et
puis une difficulté il y avait 90 places
derrière grenoble stallone a élevé un
parking qui devait être fait en même
temps que nous donc ma façade su que
vous rirez devant elle devait être
largement protégée du soleil même
complètement
donc je n'avais pas de problème
l'échauffement polycarbonate ne serait
pas c'est un effet de serre et manque de
bol le parking est en retard le parti le
gymnase est construit et jeudi au maire
de grenoble surtout n'ouvrait pas de
gymnase parce qu'il n'est pas en
condition optimale
il y en avait tellement besoin il était
tellement pressé que le blu ray en
septembre à la rentrée ou partie mort
écrit l'auteur il ouvre en avril 2013
2003 annonce le calcul est donc calculé
52 and china
parce que aussi entrepris dans doit
encore là n'avait déposé de villandraut
et donc personne ne voulait monter sur
une échelle ce n'est pas payée pour ça a
monté sur une échelle pour couvrir juste
et la peur au ventre c'est naturel parce
que s'ils tombent viscas un pied et vous
savez la responsabilité donc on était
appelée catastrophe
on est descendu je suis monté sur une
j'ai ouvert c'est que l'appel air show
est parti et puis globalement le projet
a vécu sa vie le parti n'ait été
construits mais on a eu un procès de la
ville contre nous quand vous prenez trop
de risques on a fini par gagner contre
la ville contre le maire de meaux noble
et ce projet a eu un prix parce qu'il se
comporte comme une lanterne magique en
fait c'est assez incroyable traduit un
petit quand vous rentrez dans grenoble
en train vous regardez soient bradés ce
petit gymnase plein qui est très
apprécié des étudiants qui ont fait
oublier très bien il est très haut très
lumineux il ya plus de problème
d'échauffement maintenant les faits
avait marché en ventilation naturelle à
travers sans ce projet a eu un prix et
quand on est venu de remettre au maire
de grenoble il a tourné le dos il était
troisième projet vous en présenter lui
donc c'est votre des troupes en cours
encore une prise de risque mais cette
fois porté par la confiance d'un maire
cité les élus vous savez notre métier
d'architecte est totalement liée à la
maîtrise d'ouvragé
mais cette fois ci celui qui vous donne
les ordres c'est celui qui vous fait
construire si vous demandez des
logements pas vos produits si vous les
faites et bien c'est votre faute mais
c'est aussi la faute de celui qui
voulait recommandé si vous n'êtes pas
une ombre à un autre architecte donc là
la maîtrise d'ouvragé si un jour vous
travaillez dans ce domaine la maîtrise
pas le donneur d'ordre celui qui donne
le programme est très responsable de ce
qui se construit la charrette aussi
manger l'arrondi jour tu as vu
l'architecte qui l'a fait nuit toujours
de dire que c'est l'épaule budget c'est
un mauvais programme ça et c'est donc
ici un maire extraordinaire à dunkerque
une ville un peu sinistré il veut
redonner de la vie à son à sa ville
ils mendient concours tous ces projets
se gagner sur comprendre je ne fais que
des concours
quand on est architecte toutes ces
avions fait des concours et combien ce
concours avec cette idée
simple que à dunkerque il ya 90
conscient du temps il ya du vent soit
beaucoup de vent soit un petit peu de
vent soit carrément énormément bon il ya
peut-être deux trois jours par an il n'y
a pas de vent et donc l'idée d' assez
simple on se dit en angola
on va mettre les éoliennes gratuite
petite audi tournée marins connaissent
bien ça tourne ça tourne avec le grand
et puis ça tourne c'est fait d'une telle
manière que ça va aspirer l'air des
logements où chaque état donc je
supprime ces saloperies la ventilation
mécanique contrôlée et je fais la
ventilation nocturne et c'est pour ça
que ce projet une forme assez incroyable
et c'est le projet un peu lillois comme
ça arras est complètement contemporain
ce projet est aussi un prix c'est du
logement social ou du logement accession
n'en vois pas la différence
c'est à l'entrée du port de dunkerque
tout va bien sauf que pour vendre un
logement il faut qu'ils soient certifiés
c'est à dire que les bureaux de contrôle
qui arrivent avec leurs hamacs vérifie
que la requête que je ne viens pas en
flammes à que le faux plafond si vous
tes un briquet sap a brûlé enfin bref un
principe de précaution qui fait qu'il ya
zéro risque soit 10 ans d'internement de
la colle une hache on a oublié la viande
dont les années et on continue à faire
pas mal de conneries
donc la leaf dans votre logement vous
devez un bonne humeur c'est à dire ici
on doit travailler mais visiblement il y
en a pas trois volumes heures
aujourd'hui on doit bien volume heures
c'est à dire qu'on va renouveler l'air
le volume de cette pièce en une heure
une fois comment vous garantissez vous
avez un polymers magie c'est très simple
on a fait des véhicules la roue tourne
and haas et capa mécaniques à bain je
peux pas donner mon accord nuit j'ai pas
d'actrice crise on n'a pas créé une
ligne colonnes un petit ventilateur de
telles puissances électriques un
extracteur de type sciences électrique
je valide ici je vais guibal il ya des
fenêtres
enfin laval dissous dans l'église que
l'extrait pas donc il n'a pas vu faire
une dérogation le titre 5
on n'a jamais eu cette dérogation les
logements interprètera des pendus donc
on a chaté on a fait chanter la
ventilation dominos et solide amitié
tout est prêt proposé la ventilation
naturelle n'a jamais été posée 3 l
histoire plus simple à raconter et
toujours sur lui sur l'audace que je
pense que le métier d'architecte est
forcément un métier d'innovation sauf
que vous l'avez compris dès que vous
innovez des vous faites un pas de côté
que d'être en dehors des clous de la
réglementation et pour ouvrir un
bâtiment il faut vous soyez
réglementaire moi je suis champion quand
je suis allée acheter qui avait causé le
plus chaud impôts barak s'appelle le
titre 5 c'est d'accord déroger fait un
latex un avis technique expérimentale
dans tout ce que vous devez le valider
par un dans la loi dans les temps les
codes il ya le titre 5 qui vous permet
de déroger
le problème c'est que les gens qui
donnent ce titre 5 sont les ingénieurs
qui te mêles développe la ventilation
mécanique qui peut même développe la
pompe
et de la géothermie et tous les systèmes
qui sont extrêmement lucratif
c'est un énorme marché des hommes ne
développe pas le capteur solaire
développe pas la clim solaire vous et
vous laisser d'innover vous mènera
chaque jambe innover il va c'est très
compliqué et c'est pour ça que
d'architectes innove c'est pour ça que
de métiers de l'architecturé globalement
est très en retard par rapport par
exemple l'aérospatiale donc ici c'est
très simple
une innovation pour rêver tu as des as
tu été construit à châtenay malabry une
coque blanche ou que bourdieu donc un
faisable
un trio restée plein de place on
retrouvait des gens un peu géniaux les
polonais clos poser les plaques de
plâtre sur des chefs qu'elles prennent
des formes et qu'ils ont fait c'est tout
de courbure courrier cette coque blanche
c'est une salle de 2000 places 700
places assises des 300 debout quand on
met par terre
et puis tout autour de cette corolle
dieu de cette salle une tout simplement
une derrière parce qu'on ait besoin de
se lier avec un ancien bâtiment
militaire un ancien bâtiment autour d'un
seul milieu simplifiée est donc juste du
vitrage colorée ça c'est pas compliqué à
faire c'est une idée est donc une
irisation des jours d'intense au long de
son tour passant par le bleu une espèce
de news corp réagi comme ça c'est
l'extraordinaire très théâtral qui était
a priori pas réalisable par les
ingénieurs ont dit luca et aussi à
l'intérieur vous savez entièrement en
bois et en bois avec des lamelles
différents suivant les épaisseurs hélas
cette innovation c'est pas mon
annulation ce rêve
cette poésie n'a pu se réaliser que par
ce que j'avais mais plâtrier polonais et
puis la jungle un comptable de dollars
je les crois que c'est vrai la comptable
de l'entreprise qui fait le bois qui
s'est passionné pour ce projet et
c'était tellement compliqué de dire
telle ou telle épaisseur à tel endroit
qu'elle avait un plan c'était elle
dirigeait les ouvriers de sa boîte et
eni qui était plus dans sa société en
train de caler kong
la audiard de châtenay malabry pour
mettre cette façade
je viens juste de dire une chose c'est
que la tucarella fois ci c'est que les
salles de spectacles sont jamais éclairé
la preuve c'est maintenant fermé donc là
on peut ouvrir comme une lune et puis
quand le spectacle commence on ferme 2 2
millions qui se ferme comme ça donc on
vient mettre la salle et les
professionnels du théâtre ne pouvez pas
savoir ce que c'est agréable quand on
répète dans la journée on ouvre le
lanterneau on naît la lumière
ou trop de personnes font de profits
solo alors que dans la suède en finlande
au pays c'est un droit et ça change tout
on ne peut pas spéculer sur le jour dans
d'autres villes en france
c'est un produit financier énorme
mathieu logement va mal il va pas si mal
que ça vous assure et finalement on a
besoin d'innover solo et là on est à
quatre aux heures très classique d'une
vraie passion ne s'est pas trop mal
passé mais on introduit à l'intérieur de
ce logement très simple bardage
métallique 180 mètres de long bâtiment
c'est à bordeaux et d'un conte perforé
ou au travers tous les logements une
terrasse une fenêtre une table quatre
chaises et à l'intérieur de ces deux pas
de logement recèle un atrium intérieur
comme un jardin d'hiver fermé de
s'ouvrir qui n'est pas ventilé par qui
n'est pas chauffé les baraques réchy
mais qui fonctionne naturellement pareil
avec l'inertie on prend les regards vers
son rang et ça c'est là le jardin donné
au premier étage en dessous de sa table
et c'est maintenant dessous il ya juste
un parking on n'a pas besoin d'être le
parking au sous sol pour en savoir sur
on sort dans l'atrium me rends chez soi
vous prend l'ascenseur directement
depuis la rue on n'a pas besoin de
passer par l'atrium pour entrer chez soi
vous comprendrez qu'un vaisselle mais
quand on a envie de le connaître à la
fin ils commencent à se créer dans cette
atrium une vie sociale une vie
intéressante de la commune de grands
comptes
en étudiant les chaussées logements plus
personne à 0 c'est une espèce de
condominiums c'est une espèce de projets
4e or en france
soit vous faites un atrium il ya des
règlements très précis pour la prière
ces points gros on les respecte
soit vous faites du logement il est
réellement très précis pour le jugement
de respect
le problème c'est que pouvait pas dire
j'ai fait un atrium et des logements
ce n'est pas écrit ça n'est pas
reformulé ça n'a jamais été fait
non seulement ça va péter paix mais le
code civil le code de l'urbanisme
l'hymne choses très simples on a
interdit ou non ils venaient sur un
espace intérieur
sauf si cet espace intérieur et
suffisamment ventilé on y voit assez
clair et c'est normal ouvrir une chambre
d'un enfant sur une courette parisienne
mais pour trouver beaucoup de logements
insalubres comme ça à paris donc là il a
fallu trouver que dans ces espaces là on
est exactement comme à l'extérieur mais
mieux lacan divers et l'hygiène jamais
et en été il fait toujours plus fréquent
c'est un espace interclima c'était un
parcours du combattant pire que titre 5
ça s'est terminé au ministère de
l'équipement du logement à la défense et
on a obtenu bien la préfecture et au
delà des pompiers on se retrouvait aussi
ils ont leur mot à dire mais c'est allé
très vite évidemment pour faire
pratiquement le premier logement en trio
en france c'est une deuxième
puisqu'elles
et par christian van haaren les plus
petits et là c'est à deux qu'ils sont
comme ça je dois vous dire que ça vient
découvert c'est assez inquiet parce
qu'on est dans un espace thermiquement
agréable c'était pour ses fenêtres s'il
fait chaud dehors il fait moins chaud
dans l'atrium et s'il fait froid dehors
il fait moins froid d'entrée où c'est
vraiment l'espace inter thématiques qui
économise énormément d'énergie
je reviens à l'idée de la prouesse
technique et de l'invention je pense que
on peut inventer en étant relativement
calme j'ai cité guérit tout à leurs
produits voilà la prouesse technique qui
ne sert à rien sauf à faire beau c'est à
dire faire des cavs des choses attendues
dans tous les sens pour faire une belle
sculpture c'est peut-être de la prouesse
technique mais ça nous donne ça donne
rien à rien san san san humain ça ne
profite pas au profil peut-être pour les
yeux mais c'est entre guillemets un
gâchis d'argent
aujourd'hui ça viendrait une période
c'est pas très drôle ce que je vais dire
mais moi je le sens comme ça on est bien
on devrait peut-être dans la cèze on a
été beaucoup dans la consommation
il ya un moment où cette planète on nous
parlait déjà de quoi me mets à cette
planète ne peut plus et moi je sous le
sens urbanistes architectes sont énormes
prochaine ce moment je sens qu'il faut
faire beaucoup de choses avec tous et
palais six morts ces deux morts with
less et ça c'est un peu il est d'un
rénovation d'un projet dont on n'a pas
touché l'extérieur c'est à strasbourg
sur le deck nationale universitaire est
une magnifique nanterre 90 la coupole
qui était complètement fermée pour les
enfermer des visiteurs
donc on a enlevé tous les planchers on a
tous refaire c'est un projet énorme
projet de restauration est au coeur de
ce
de ce dôme on a installé cet escalier
hélicoïdal qui se serait tracy petit à
petit vous voyez sur la coupe qui est
tenu en partie par ces câbles convergent
vers le haut et en fait ça passe et
carey de la volt peut l'aider car ici
c'est comme ça et pas dans ce rond point
ici et ensuite et bien s'ouvrir en
spirale
tout autour de ce grand d'atrium où il
avait sa blessure mais en fait on a créé
d'une situation de cette coupole ouvert
comme ça un endroit où tous les gens pas
se retrouvent discutent choisissent
leurs classes à vienne est ouvert c'est
que vous avez la france vous ça n'a été
possible que grâce au savoir-faire des
compagnons serrurier métallier